Guys, the Overwatch League may have only one season to its name but it’s already provided
us with some unforgettable caster calls.
From the hype.
(Casting)
to hilarious wordplay.
To moments so intense, the casters
physically buckled under the pressure.
(Casting)
It’s safe to say some of these calls will go down as truly iconic in the history of
pro Overwatch.
And if you wanna be as Iconic as I am now, well you can pick up this t-shirt and plenty more
at theScore esports new online merch department.
A truly iconic link, will be pinned in the comment section below.
Now without further ado, let's get on with it with the top 10 caster calls from Overwatch League Season 1.
Kicking off our list at number 10 is the moment when Carpe effectively became the first player
in the Overwatch League to go absolutely HAM on Widowmaker.
Even casters Doa and Montecristo seemed as
if they were taken off-guard by Carpe’s
lethal skills.
(Casting)
Sometimes a play is so absurdly sick, that the only sentiment a caster can muster is rage.
Coming in at number nine is Uber becoming audibly upset with TviQ as the player takes
out an airborne Pharah with Genji’s Deflection ability.
(Casting)
Uber is revered not only for his incredible casting, but for the shamelessness of his
wordplay which is why this one comes in at
number eight on our list.
When confronted with the Houston Outlaws’ cheesy use of a shield-protected Bastion turret,
the Philadelphia Fusion made such an improbable
turn that Uber couldn’t help but dish out
a juicy pun at the Outlaws’ expense.
(Casting)
During the London Spitfire’s Stage 1 Final against the New York Excelsior, Profit guided a game-winning
JunkRat ultimate into the back of Ark’s Mercy.
And coming in at number seven is Semmler’s
glorious effort to add Profit’s hundred-thousand-dollar
Rip-Tire to esports’ already-existing group of monetized ultimates.
(Casting)
The number sixth entry on our list reminds us that Overwatch
is a game in which the line between carry and support is especially fuzzy.
Watch and listen as Uber tries to keep Neptuno in check as the Fusion player’s Battle Mercy
leverages a two-man revival into a triple kill, redefining what it means to ‘swoop in for the rescue’.
(Casting)
A big part of being in the Overwatch League is being a god with projectile heroes.
And coming in at number five, we have Hagopeun who puts on a Zenyatta snipeshow against the
Boston Uprising.
Even a caster as composed and calculating as Uber couldn’t help but shout random phrases
as the spiritual support held his ground.
(Casting)
Coming in at number
four we have the call that followed the infamous 4K that Pine scored against the London Spitfire
in Junkertown.
Doa and Montecristo can’t even watch the replay of Pine’s final flick shot without
entering a state of utter disbelief.
(Casting)
The third spot on our list sees the return of Carpe’s already legendary Widowmaker.
Watch as the South Korean assassin squeezes off two of the nastiest headshots you’ll
ever see in such quick succession that even the Rap God himself struggles to keep his composure.
(Casting)
If there’s anything to learn from our runner-up, it’s that nicknames can only ever be earned.
During New York Excelsior’s Stage 1 match against the Houston Outlaws, ‘Big Boss Pine’
conducted a master class in McCree, causing Doa to bellow Pine’s now notorious nickname
with such fervour that it solidified the size of the South Korean superstar’s authority once and for all.
(Casting)
Taking the top spot on our list is an epic yet innocuous line that won’t soon be forgotten.
During the LA Gladiators’ first playoff match against Spitfire, Uber made an observation
about Surefour’s exhilarating decision to ’chill in base’ -- which has since come
to be regarded as one of the greatest strategic maneuvers in the game's competitive history.
(Casting)
Well guys that's our list for this week, now did we miss out on your favourite Overwatch League
Season 1 caster call, well let us know in the comments below, leave a like and don't forget to sub to the channel.
See ya next week.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.